[Musique]
il partage avec François baayrou un
attachement pour le même territoire et
une amitié de plus de 40 ans mon invité
a été un peu macroniste avant l'heure
centriste dans l'âme il préside le
groupe modem à l'Assemblée avec un style
unique parfois
[Musique]
déroutant bonjour Jean-P ti bonjour
alors en général on attend d'un
président de groupe qui fasse un peu
régner l'ordre dans ses rangs sauf
qu'avec vous président du groupe modem
c'est parfois l'inverse qui se produit
notamment pendant le débat budgétaire
2022 vous avez mené la fronde contre le
gouvernement avec un amendement pour
taxer les super dividendes des grandes
entreprises on va réentendre ceux qui
ont pris la parole dans l'hémicycle pour
vous soutenir parce que c'est assez
étonnant on va voter l'amendement de
notre collègue parce qu'il prend le
pognon là où il faut le prendre pour
pour le donner là où on a besoin je
crois que c'est une mesure de bon sens
et qui devrait rassembler extrêmement
largement sur ces bans donc oui nous
votre dispositif c'est un amendement
très raisonnable très constructif qui à
mon avis peut rassembler tout le monde
pour avancer sur un sujet qui fera du
bien à la démocratie et à la justice
fiscale résultat du scrutin pour 227
contre
88 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté al
vient d'entendre dans l'ordre Sébastien
jumelle pour le Parti communiste manuel
bonpard pour la France insoumise et
Jean-Philippe Tanguy pour le
rassemblement national tous ont voté
votre amendement contre l' viis du
gouvernement est-ce que vous êtes
vraiment dans votre rôle de président de
groupe de la majorité quand vous faites
cela est-ce que je suis dans mon rôle de
président de groupe en tout cas j'ai
j'ai une forte conviction sur cette
mesure qui est un signe hein comme je
l'ai dit dans l'hémicycle il s'agissait
pas d'un grand soir fiscal mais
simplement d'une mesure qui pour moi
était de bon sens alors effectivement
euh j'ai peut-être pas pris conscience
de mon rôle de président de groupe à ce
moment-là et mais je pense que mon
groupe était totalement derrière
d'ailleurs il a il a voté ils ont tous
voté l'amendement vous dites j'ai
peut-être pas pris conscience c'estd il
y a peut-être C non je cherchais pas
coup cherchez pas un coup politique pour
moi il était important d'envoyer un
petit signe la société éta un peu
crispée et je trouvais qu'il allit dans
le bon sens d'ailleurs l'ensemble des
des intervenants le le soulignne euh
j'ai pas cherché à faire un j'ai
simplement voulu que l'on vote une
mesure pour moi de bon sens vous
comprenez que certains responsables de
la majorité vous considèent un peu comme
un anquikineur et je reste poli voir
comme un dangereux gauchiste parce que
vous en avez fait d'autres des des coups
un peu comme ça sur la thématique de la
fiscalité qui est vraiment votre domaine
de prédilection non mais je moi je suis
un profond libéral et je pense que il
peut y avoir des mesures de justice
fiscale qui vont qui accompagnent est-ce
que c'est de gauche est-ce que c'est de
droite non c'était des mesures de bon
sens j'envoyais un signe et je encore
une fois je je cherchais pas à jouer les
front tireurs ou les fronteurs mais
simplement apporter ma pierre au débat
budgétaire et je pense que le budgétaire
av besoin de respirer d'envoyer quelques
signes notamment aux gens qui galèrent
un peu alors il y a eu les super
dividendes mais il y a aussi eu les
rachats d'actions par les grosses
entreprises ou encore la niche fiscale
derbynb sur tous ces sujets de de
fiscalité vous avez porté des mesures
qui sont plébiscitées par la gauche
est-ce que vous êtes au courant des
surnoms que vous ont donné les
différents députés j' entendu
quelquesuns je crois qu'on m'a on m'a
traité de de camarade mat je crois que
c'est jumelle qui m' TR euh
de notaire révolutionnaire notaire
révolutionnaire voilà ou l'insous mati
ça c'est Adrien Clouet de la France il y
a même un article qui m'a traité de punk
je crois voilà ou de Pun et il paraît
que les écologistes ont imprimé des des
t-shirt à c'est ce qu'on ma c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit moi j'ai pas vu les
t-shirts mais c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
qu'il y avait eu des t-shirts imprimés
star des députés de gauche vous vous non
je cherche pas être la star des députés
de gauche franchement je cherche
simplement à à montrer qu'on peut
dialoguer et trouver des des points
d'atrissage sur certains sujets je mais
je ne rêve pas je ne rêve pas je sais
très bien que même si certaines de mes
mesures avaient été adopté c'est pas
pour autant que la gauche aurait voté le
projet de loi de finance effectivement
quand vous dites président de groupe
c'est vrai que le mandat précédent
j'étais pas président de groupe j'ai
porté des amendements sur
uneaugmentation de la FLAC taxe ça a
fait moins bruit moins de bruit voilà
effectivement vous avez travaillé main
dans la main avec plusieurs députés de
gauche sur des questions de fiscalité en
trouvant des compromis notamment avec
Erric coqurel il était pas encore
président de la commission des finances
à l'époque mais c'était déjà aussi son
son domaine de prédilection est-ce que
ça veut dire que cette opposition
frontale à laquelle on assiste entre LFI
et le gouvernement dans l'hémicycle
c'est du spectacle et que il serait
possible de trouver des accords
ponctuellement avec LFI moi je pense
qu'on peut trouver avec certains membres
d' LFI des des points d'atterrissage sur
certain sujet avec éc cocrel on avait
déposé un amendement en commun sur le
fait qu'un dirigeant de grande
entreprise française pe ses impôts en
France éit un peu en écho à ce qui
s'était passé avec Carlos Gon on a on a
trouvé des des compromis il y a une part
de mise en
scèneou de la politique il il est
certain que bon moi j'ai je suis dans
l'émicycle comme à l'extérieur voilà je
peux difficilement changer de style pour
moi c'est c'est c'est compliqué de
d'avoir un autre style dans l'hémicycle
à l'extérieur bon vous avez des putés
qui sont un peu en scène qui font des
capsules vidéo bon voilà moi je sais pas
ce que je cherche je suis pas un fan
politique spectacle mais attention je
pense que un parlement on parle on débat
et que il faut pas critiquer les grandes
envolés lyriques je pense qu'elles sont
nécessaires au débat parlementairire je
suis un peu moins sur ce style voilà
chacun sa sa façon de voir les choses il
y a autre chose qui fait de vous un
président de groupe assez iconoclaste
vous expliquez que vous êtes arrivé à ce
poste un peu par hasard c'est possible
ça de devenir chef en politique par
hasard alors euh je je m'étais pas
préparé à être président de groupe moi
j'ai fait dernier quinquen j'ai fait un
mandat assez assidu où je travaillais en
commission des finances passionné par
tout ce que je faisais j'étais
vice-président de du groupe modem à
l'époque il s'appelait pas démocrate
modem et indépendant bon il se trouve
que Patrick Mignola qui qui avait pris
la suite de Marc F éé battu donc en 2022
aux élections législatives et donc
certains de mes collègues ont souhaité
que je me présente et j'ai présenté ma
candidature et j'ai été élu à la
présidence de ce groupe et je suis
totalement investi dans ce dans ce poste
le hasard s'est transformé en
détermination on va dire et alors vous
avez une conception assez particulière
de votre rôle de président de groupe
vous expliquez j'ai un rôle d'animateur
j'essaie de mettre de la rondeur dans
les relations je suis un peu le tonton
du groupe le paternel attentif ça veutd
que pour vous ce poste de président de
groupe n'est pas un poste politique
c'est un poste politique mais il est pas
fait pour me pour pour voir moi mon but
c'est d'être créatif et je pense que la
créativité vous l'avez à travers des
femmes et des hommes qui ont tous des
talents et donc moi mon mon mon rôle est
de faire émerger ces talents et qu'il
soit mis en avant je cherche pas à me
mettre moi en avant c'est pas mon rôle
premier il y a a un autre point qui m'a
qui a arrêté mon mon attention vous vous
dressez un parallèle entre les raisons
qui vous ont fait choisir la profession
de notaire et les raisons qui vous vous
ont fait vous engager en en politique
euh vous dites que c'est pour mettre les
gens d'accord oui moi j'adore le
compromis je je pense que et un notire
c'est c'est pareil c'est ah oui mais un
notire c'est quelqu'un qui qui passe sa
vie à mettre les gens d'accord dans les
partages de famille dans les conflits
entre voisins on est là pour apaiser
donc c'est assez facile ensuite dans
votre vie politique et notamment quand
j'étais maire de d'avoir cette action de
compromis mettre les gens d'accord pas
pe qu' des conflits il faut qu'on
aboutisse il faut qu'on se mette
d'accord voilà si vous êtes engagé en
politique c'est aussi pour soutenir une
personne en particulier vous expliquez
avoir flaché pour giscar quand vous
étiez en terminale vous êtes tellement
passionné pour lui que je crois que
votre mère est convaincu que c'est à
cause de giscar vous avez loupé votre
max ça absolument ma mère qui n'est plus
de ce monde m'avait m'avait reproché un
peu de d'être très engagé effectivement
à
l'époque cet homme m'a séduit cette
façon de faire la politique un peu un
peu hors norme vous savez quand je vois
ce qui le parcours du président Emmanuel
Macron valergist cardestin peut-être un
peu plus d'antériorité en politique mais
est arrivé comme ça et quand on est
jeune on avait pas le droit de vote en
en 74 le droit de vote était à 21 ans
j'avais pas le droit de vote voilà je me
suis engagé je me suis passionné pour
cette cause là effectivement j'ai un peu
délaissé à ce moment-là mon travail en
terminale et vous avez très vite pris
des responsabilités dans le mouvement
des jeunes giscardiens qui s'appelaiit à
l'époque génération social et libéral
vous avez même gardé la carte de membre
je crois que vous la portez presque tout
le temps sur vous tout le temps je peux
même vous la sortir sur vous je crois
que je l'ai je l'ai là enfin je la porte
pas tout le temps mais je savais qu'il
allait avoir oui j'ai trouvé ça l'autre
jour en rangeant dans mes archives et je
trouvé sympa alors vous savez génération
sociale et libérale c'est tout à fait
dans la ligne de ce que je pens oui un
libéral humaniste social moi tout ça ça
me va très bien et alors à la fac de
peau vous avez monté un syndicat
étudiant qui s'appelait la garbure la
garbure étudiant la garbure étudiante
qui avait pour objectif de rassembler
des gens de sensibilités politiques
différentes plus tard quand vous avez
monté votre propre liste pour devenir
maire de Ger en 2001 euh vous êtes allé
chercher des gens de tous les bords
politiques droite et gauche en fait le
le macronisme ce n'est rien d'autre que
du mathéisme oui ENF on va rester à sa
place j'ai eu cette chance euh de d'être
à la tête d'une commune de 2000
habitants pendant pendant 16 ans avec
effectivement des gens de tous les bords
voilà vous avez au moment du mariage
pour tous par exemple il y a eu un peu
de crise paion dans mon dans mon équipe
mais tout ça ça s'est apaisé on faisait
on faisait des choses avec des
conceptions différentes on faisait des
choses et je trouve que c'est une très
belle expérience ça fonctionne moi je
pense que ça peut fonctionner et je
rêverais que on y arrive à l'Assemblée
alors il y a il y a une autre personne
que giscar qui a compé dans votre
parcours politique c'est François
baayrou vous le connaissez depuis 1976
c'est un ami il était présent à votre
mariage il vous a demandé de d'être son
suppléant en 2012 lors de la Législative
perdu àôt c'est lui qui vous a demandé
vous présenter en 2017 aux législativ
euh quelle est la nature de votre
relation politique avec François
baayerou je pose la question parce que
dans la majorité il y en a qui ont un
peu l'impression que quand vous parlez
c'est François Baayou qui parle il y
avait un responsable de la majorité qui
anonymement disait dans le Figaro
Jean-François Matth JEP mat Jean-Paul
Matth pardon c'est la voix de son maître
François Baayou m'appelle rarement pour
me dire faut faire si çale on n'est pas
du tout dans cette relation on a on se
voit on se rencontre mais euh on n pas
je ne reçois pas de consigne h
d'ailleurs j'aurais du mal à à les
accepter non pas que ça m'agacerait vite
donc je suis pas sous curatel ou tutelle
j'ai une profonde admiration pour le
personnage son parcours euh une forte
amitié et un fort respect voilà mais on
n pas dans une relation du maître la
voix de son maître non pas du tout en
tout cas je le ressens pas comme ça et
je pense que lui a la même vision des
choses ouais on va passer à notre quiz à
présent je vous explique le le principe
je vais commencer des phrases ça va être
à vous de les compléter pas si je vais
savoir faire mais oui vous allez voir
c'est très simple c'est parti à chaque
fois qu'on m'appelle Jean-François mat
justement je je l'ai fait il y a
quelques instants ouais ben je pense au
ministre de la Santé ça vous agace ou
non pas vraiment parce que c'était
quelqu'un de respectable je connais pas
il il a été dans la famille centriste
aussi voilà un joli un très beau
parcours ais voilà non au contraire bon
vous saz les mathéistes est un nom assez
courant en Corse voilà mais ça me ça me
vexe pas ça ne me crispe pas parce que
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour son
parcours ma dernière discussion en tête
à-tête avec Bruno Le
Maire ça mais ça remonte à la semaine
dernière au moment du Congrès des Maires
ah vous saz il avait fait un pot avec
l'ensemble des maires donc on a échangé
il ça s'est bien passé parce que avit un
peu en conflit quand même à plusieurs
reprisz je pense qu'il y a un respect
mutuel euh Breno le maire a éé un
ministre des Finances courageux avec un
grand talent je partage pas tout à fait
sa vision je trouve parfois un peu sur
certains sujets mais j'ai pas toutes ces
contraintes en tout cas moi je suis dans
mon rôle de législateur et lui il est
dans son rôle de je dirais de ministre
des Finances enfin si je devais choisir
un député avec qui traverser
l'Atlantique à la voile parce que vous
êtes de voile alors il y aurait soit
Jimmy pin ah bah oui c'est vrai ancien
skip par que parce que lui il sa'est
faire et pourquoi pas erriic cocrel et
oui parce que c'est ce que j'avais en
tête lui il a organisé des courses
transatlantiques à la voile oui pourquoi
pas et ben les trois ensemble sur un
même bateau ça serait pas mal merci
beaucoup Jean-Paul mat d'être venu la
politique et moi
[Musique]
merci